Dude. All right, look, or this is what I'm going to do.
I'm going to talk about this because it's been in my notes for literally five
months. It's called. I wrote down the deserve at scale. All right.
Now one fire is always like, what the is the deserve at scale?
And it's been on the notes and we laugh because it's so dumb.
The deserve it scale made about as much sense to him as a scab. All right.
The deserve its scale is,
is I think we might've maybe touched on this in a podcast before, but
a video online of a guy falling,
just the guy falling and he doesn't deserve it is
not as, I mean, it can be funny. There's always exceptions,
but the deserve its scale is what makes it funny to me.
Okay.
If a guy's twirling plates on a basketball and falls down,
his dessert scale is off the charts and I'm
harder because he's a, yeah, you understand?
I know he's going to fall. And he doesn't.
There was a video of a kid
on top of referral of a, of a cupboard.
This was a long time ago in, um,
on America's funniest, home videos. You know,
back when the internet wasn't a thing.
And this kid was on the top of the cupboard and he was going to scary,
set up the camera was going to scare his family.
And it was just going to be great, right? Set up the whole thing.
The kid goes around here and slips his pants catch on the top of the cupboard
and he falls down and his crack is facing the camera.
Now that deserve it. Scale is off the charts because he set it all up,
stood on the cupboard and waited for his dad.
So it was so funny, dude. Here's another good one, man.
One time there was a guy skiing down a mountain, bro. I lost my at this. Okay.
And he was skiing down the mountain and the guy was at the bottom of the
slope filming it. He was like, okay, here we come. Join up. Like so far away,
the guy was just sh sh sh sh doing the that scares you.
Sh sh sh you're a super of your skiing, you know?
And he gets close to the guy with the camera and the guy with the
camera, you can just sense. You know,
there was just like a sense that he had where he was like, uh, Oh,
some about to go down and the guy go,
the guy skiing says, Oh, sorry, Chris.
And then smashes into the guy with the camera
because he said, sorry, before I, bro,
if you know, you're going to up,
can't stop and apologize beforehand.
The deserve at scale. So high, first of all,
don't even shoot it. Just let the guy live life.
The best deserve. At scale though, I ever saw was at a wedding.
This was the funniest home videos. I've looked this video up forever online.
There was a wedding going on. And the,
I guess it was the groom that on the indoors wedding,
in a gymnasium or wherever the, this thing was,
he gets on the motorcycle that was
there for some reason at K.
Now the deserve its scale,
dude is that Mach 10. All right.
This guy's on a first of all motorcycle in a
gymnasium.
That's not it at a wedding.
That's not it at his wedding. All right.
The deserve its scale. I mean, if there was a weight sensor, it would be.
[Inaudible].
Okay. Now this guy revs it and he is just,
he seems dope as. Okay.
Cause he had on, I remember he had on like a, not a traditional thing.
He had him like a cool thing cause he wanted to look cool on the motorcycle
thing. And,
and he went to take off and he got
wrong and obviously didn't know how to ride a motorcycle that well,
because he didn't let go of the handle and the motorcycle kept going.
And he was doing like the womb and he tried to stand up off of it because it got
to him and the motorcycle went into all the decorations and took out all the
decorations and ruin the wedding dude. And I cried.
The disservice scale was Mach 10.
And I think that's when I created the dessert scale when I was a kid. Anyway,
what I want you to do because I love dessert. Scale videos.
Send your favorite deserve at scale videos. Okay. Now,
you know, there's different levels. Like the skiing one wasn't so high,
but the motorcycle at the wedding one was just off the charts. Right?
You ever see the grape smash one where the girl's like, okay.
And go and they're on a level up and they're smashing the grapes and it's a,
you know, middle-aged woman. That's like portly and she's like, go, go, go, go,
go, go, go. And then she falls off of the level thing. And then he's like, Oh.
Oh you remember that? Did.
You ever see it fire at one fire? You seen it? Oh man, let's watch that one.
That one is such a high desert scale. Oh man.
When I would watch this on E bombs world, when I was 12,
smashing fail.
She's so out of breath, great lady falls. Original. Sad to be the great lady.
What kind of grid? These are filled with chamber sin,
grapes and the winner this Saturday, he stopped music, eating international.
Best thing is they both,
they both have zero clue that this about to go down.
And my favorite thing about it is I know it's going to go down.
That's the best because otherwise, why would it even be on the internet?
One dude,
I used to love America's home videos because they would show the video.
And you knew you were smarter than the idiot on the camera.
You knew some was going to go down and they had no idea.
And I would just sit there, giddy with this, Oh,
I can't wait for this guy to fall. And they would fall. And I would,
the would just be an Uber sensation or they
are so here they are.
This Saturday, he's talking music, eating international foods,
having wine tours and tastings, vineyard.
Platform. That's like, I mean,
it's like three and a half feet up. What?
A bad idea dude.
And why are they wearing the same thing? Cause they work for the place.
And it's a sad, the whole thing. Here we go.
Seminars, arts and crafts. Oh.
I remember what happens to before we've been watching.
She stops and they're like, okay, stop.
And then th this is what made it extra funny. She was like, wait, wait,
wait a little bit more. And that's when she falls.
It's a lot of fun. A whole day. Stop
I'll stop. Oh
no. Oh dear. She's actually hurt. Oh yeah buddy.
You say that you regular guy.
And the winner this Saturday he's stopped music, eating international,
having wine, tasting tours, seminars, arts, and crafts.
It's a lot of fun a whole day.
Okay. She says stop. Now. She's even though it's a joke.
It's it's what you gets. It's what you gets, man. I'm sorry lady.
But you're on a four-foot platform up. That is so small.
It could be an elevator. It's the size of an elevator.
And then you're stomping, slippery, gray.
And then you don't stop after you say stop. And even as a joke,
that's not the rules lady. You said stop. You said it by the way.
And then she goes, she goes a little bit more like a
We've all been there.
She can't not breathe out because it hit and she can't not breathe
out.
She's in so much pain that she just lets a little bit of sound out and it just
turns into.
She.
Can't think of breath in bro. That's so funny. I feel bad,
but she's probably okay. That's the other thing too. If you know,
they've done some permanent damage and it's not funny anymore.
Cause you feel bad, but I think this lady's okay. She's at the top.
She's at the top level of, I think she's okay.
Is she went any further than it's not okay.
Like those skateboarding videos where people fall down and break their femurs.
I'm not into that. This here.
She saying stop.
She doesn't realize what she's saying because there's nothing to be stopped.
That's the best.
That's also very funny because he's just saying stop because she's like praying
to the gods that this should stop, but she can't.
Oh
no. I think she is actually hurt. No, I think she is.
She took a hard fall off there. Oh gosh. I hope she's okay. Okay.
We're going to make sure she is check on her and get back to you as soon as we
can. And we'll be back right after this.
Oh man. Okay. Let's read about her here.
We'll go up. Yeah. So, okay. Oh wow. There's a whole story here.
Oh, okay.
Melissa Sanders was a reporter for an Atlanta TV station in the late nineties,
doing a fluff report from a local winery.
She participated in an impromptu grape stomping contest when disaster
hilariously struck memoed appearance. If this is what I was saying,
if you really want to show your kids that cheaters never prosper,
you might want to consider using this video as visual aid. Exactly.
Even though it was a light competition, you stop. When you say stop.
After being told that time was upstate standard.
By the way it was her that said the time was up. I mean, look at the way.
This is written.
Sander kept stomping and was quickly slapped
by the hand of fate tumbling over the side.
You know her Waldorf like screams while obviously, I mean wrote this.
Well obviously I'm using her to our coworkers in the studio. No, they were sad.
Seem to indicate a serious injury.
There's somebody in the comments section claiming Sandra broke several ribs and
almost died. Oh, come on. They think it's funnier that way.
They're saying push it, go back up. She was fine. Said she was fine.
Click on that. Oh wait, hold on.
And by the way was basically her fault because they chose to film facing the
side. Yeah. Really? Without railings click on that.
No that, Oh you got it. Oh, okay.
Go back. Yeah. Go read down. I want to read down. According to bloggers,
who've tried to track her down shortly after the incident sander left Atlanta
for Albany,
which we're sure had nothing to do with the fact that the in-studio reports were
barely holding back giggles at her pain yodeling.
Our bio page has a bio page and Albany makes no mud,
no mention of a near death experience due to Pierce appear salon,
which further supports. I mean, what the is this? You know,
people will just be like, think anything's a conspiracy.
She's no longer the jaw dropped off the face of the earth.
Let's try to find her, you know, go up, go up,
click her bio page right there. Oh, there it is.
It's probably not up anymore. Right? Yeah. It's not there anymore.
Well, we wish her all the best here it congratulations. You know? Um,
but the deserve at scale was mighty high on that one.
Wasn't quite as big as the motorcycle in the but man.
No railings.
Uh, if I was working there and that happened while she was falling, I'd be like,
we knew it.